some parents who are unhappy with ccsd's
reopening plan are now considering home
schooling their kids
eight news now reporter kate houston
spoke to one parent and homeschooling
advocate about the upcoming school year
homes across the valley could soon be
turning into full-time classrooms
as parents take their child's education
into their own hands
as a parent i was mortified
carly iu recalls her reaction when she
saw the clark county school district's
reopening plan
her son shiloh was going into the second
grade and she wants him home
i don't know where the other children
have been and i don't know where the
teacher has been
the uncertainty of covid 19 and the
district's plan
are enough for parents like iu to
withdraw their kids and do it themselves
when i started seeing how it was
progressing
more and more i was like going to the
direction of homeschooling
she's not alone rise education resource
center which assists families wanting to
home school
has seen a large uptick in parents
calling for information
a lot of them are feeling frustrated so
looking at homeschooling as an option
puts them in more of the director scene
wall says parents should instruct their
kids with a mix of academics
socializing pe and field trips the best
thing
you can do is really create a rich
educational environment
help them love learning open up doors
and that way when they go back to school
they can slide right in
she adds that some typical mistakes
parents can make are trying to exactly
replicate school at home
and buying an overpriced curriculum if a
parent is considering
wall recommends researching different
education styles
to see what fits their child's needs
kate houston 8 news now
so if you're considering homeschooling
for your child there are some steps that
you need to take
you will need to formally withdraw your
child from school
and then file a notice of intent with an
educational plan